fauci um
was doing an interview he said that it's
almost like there are two americas due
to people who are not getting the
vaccine
and uh it's it's fascinating he's
correct i've talked about this before
let's say you live in texas where they
have no restrictions no lockdowns i
think it's oregon that started saying
they want to implement vaccine passports
so if you're from texas no more tourism
in oregon not that a lot of texans
wanted to go there anyway like to be
completely honest probably other way
around people fleeing portland to texas
but let's say you're in florida you want
to go to new york well new york says
we're going to do the excelsior pass for
like madison square garden you got to be
able to prove your vaccination status so
you can't so can't go see the foo
fighters so now people in states without
the restrictions who are abiding by the
law and regulations and guidelines won't
be able to go to other states
now that is where it gets crazy because
for the longest time we have we have
open travel between states when this
whole thing started we had there were
there were checkpoints set up at new
york going in and they would you know i
don't know exactly what they were doing
but there were stories that from like
new york to content to connecticut
connecticut had um police at the border
checking plates that were from new york
because they were like new york's a hot
spot so we're actually starting to see
a re-emergence of borders in the u.s and
laws that prohibit people from free
travel or from
actually being able to use
accommodations public accommodations in
certain states does that apply to amazon
drivers too
and truck drivers yes and this is where
a lot of people in our super chats have
brought this up that a truck a trucker
who's from say nebraska is going to be
dr they're like hey this one's going to
new york can't go sorry
oh well this one's going to oregon oh
yeah i can't go there
well he could but he's going to have to
drive around this one state right well
let's say the destination is is oregon
and they're like well no they're doing
vaccine passports in oregon the guy's
gonna say where do i go to the bathroom
and get food i'm not going sorry find
someone else to drive and we're already
dealing with apparently the shortage
with truckers so now a bunch of people
that there's fuel like gas stations
aren't getting the fuel they need
you add in these heavy restrictions
which so far hasn't taken off for the
most part but we we are seeing it happen
in certain areas it's not even about
that's what people need to understand
you don't need to ban people who aren't
vaccinated you need only apply pressure
so that could mean
oh you can everyone's free to come here
vaccinated or unvaccinated but if you're
not vaccinated you gotta go in the back
that's pressure and some people are
gonna say i'm not i'm not interested in
being the guy in the back room so have a
nice day
portland can say we don't truckers are
allowed to come don't worry we're not
banning people who aren't vaccinated but
you can't go to these select gas
stations and these restaurants are off
limits and most of the companies here
are required it so you'll you'll figure
it out they're like i'm not i'm not i'm
not taking that stress
so that that pressure is enough
to dramatically alter this country i
find it fascinating when you have all
this talk of peaceful divorce due to the
extremism the violence and now you have
actual bureaucratic pressure which is
starting to emerge two americas yeah you
got that you got that divide and conquer
thing going on
and
um
i mean this is this should just be
completely common sense there are some
people who cannot take these vaccines
right right so if you've already had an
anaphylactic reaction in a prior vaccine
episode which has happened a lot of
people you are not a candidate accessory
on the cdc website right which
apparently you can still get in trouble
for quoting this stuff right but there
it is and they say oh by the way and if
you've had the first shot and you have a
really bad reaction that passes certain
threshold you shouldn't get the second
so you are now not fully vaccinated on
and on it's a complex situation there
there is a band i forgot their name i
don't care they said a thousand dollars
to see the the the event but uh a
discount
if you're vaccinated it'll only cost you
18 yeah i saw that and there was a woman
who was a fan who gave an interview
where she said because she had kovid
recently the doctors told her she was
ineligible for the time being and she
had to come back later so that meant she
wasn't able to go to the show but guess
what rich people come on in baby it's
all yours
it's a rich man's world
yeah it has been for 10 000 years or
something well and here's the problem
with all this it it doesn't logically
you can't parse your way through it
doesn't make sense so so if we let's go
back to first principles what's the
point of all this the point of all this
should be public health i guess yes
right
yes i don't know anymore to be honest i
don't know either suspension of human
life no i it's society and species yes
that is should should be but certainly
uh never let a good crisis go to waste
right that's the saying there's a lot
and it was interesting because we had
destiny uh here he's the he's like a
leftist streamer and i said you know it
looks like we're seeing people exploit
the crisis and he goes
when else would you try and make
sweeping changes in reforms you know
this
what what better time than now when
where we have to lock things down now's
our opportunity and i'm like then would
you trust every move made if you knew
people were simply saying we got a
crisis great let's let's let's do a
bunch of things we always wanted to do
oh so that means um let's support uh
people going to mcdonald's and getting
crispy green donuts and shopping at
walmart but we're going to shut down
small and medium-sized enterprises right
you know this is
is that the crisis they wanted to
exploit we want we want the little
people to take it in the shorts i
thought that was not a lefty thing i
gotta admit though there is a confusion
there is a real problem with a lack of
personal responsibility people should
not be gorging on donuts and mcdonald's
and they should be you know doing better
eating better and exercising and uh
but
it's a personal responsibility it's 100
right it is and it is that's the
conversation i wish that was on the news
every day is how to get healthy yeah
right how to feel better but they i i
think this is this is uh
exclusively of the democrats well i
shouldn't say exclusively but it's the
rule not the exception where they want
you dependent they want you dependent
they want you on social programs they
want you to feel like no matter what you
do you'll never succeed without their
help
it's free look at this what's what's the
critical race theory message
you are oppressed and no matter what you
do because the color of your skin you
will always be oppressed or oppressor
and you need us to help you to navigate
these problems versus the other message
of you can be anything you want to be if
you believe in it
too many leaders they don't want too
many leaders what's that what's a good
ratio of leader to follower in the human
race
one yeah one to one no no
yeah one to nine billion one one
despotic king no one to nine billion
what is it like one one to twelve one to
sixty
it's it's not five it's no no but hold
on it's not about one leader at all it's
about specialists
you know if uh
if if someone came in this room and said
i need
to know what magic cards to buy i'd be
like take it away ian like yeah
lightning no i like that ball lightning
it holds a special place no i mean like
what are you what are you an expert in
if someone came in and said i need
someone to fix the toilet i beg at any
ian like you're not a plumber
so you're a leader in the right moment
and so you know
leaders step up when they're when
they're called into action oh yeah and
you can inspire people to to
to seize their ability to lead yeah
everyone's good at something dude if uh
uh if if you know we had someone out
here and and they were a farmer and a
wildlife expert and and and you know uh
like a vacation like a doctor you know
like if someone came out here and they
were an expert in plant life i would
immediately be like tell me where to go
what to do what to wear and tell me how
to find the fruits and that guy's in
charge but then if he comes in and says
we're gonna do we're in talk podcasts
i'll be like okay well it ain't you
buddy like i'll i'll step up if we're
doing a podcast thing you'll step up
when you're doing a fruits and berries
in the forest thing
it's like recognizing where you are not
the leader and recognizing where you are
and then so we have oligarchs or
corporations that are attempting to lead
the narrative when we have doctors that
are more specialized that maybe would be
better off deciding what should and
shouldn't be talked about don't go to a
dentist for foot care right and don't go
to a social network for health care
right oh i love it when facebook is like
instagram is giving medical advice and
facebook is and all the celebrities are
and posting these things but heaven
forbid joe rogan have an opinion
or
a critical care doctor who's been eat
lives breathes drinks this and his
indisputable world leader on this stuff
right so
but this says nothing about that's why i
said first principles it's about public
health it's clearly not it's not about
that it's about something else so we can
you know assign motives and all that
it's clearly about the money it's about
the benjamins it's about power it's
about seizing the moment to ram through
some things that otherwise couldn't have
been rammed through it's a pie chart
it's a you know somewhere in there is it
is a nice little chunk of public health
but then you you get greedy hands man
and people see an opportunity to exploit
a crisis
and you know what the path to hell is
paved with good intentions well listen
if if i saw them exploiting a way that i
could detect and say okay i get it not
how i do it but it makes sense it does
it's still incoherent it doesn't make
sense to me right the only thing that's
starting to emerge in this pattern is
as soon as i saw the climate lockdowns
we have to do climate lockdowns that's
when the piece has started to fall for
me i think
i think this well
you take a look at texas in florida they
were like ah we out so it's clearly not
a unified message in terms of our
government
there are different jurisdictions with
different beliefs and different people
are exploiting different things
and i think one of the reasons it may
not be cohesive is just that
there's it's a chicken with his head cut
off man
it's that's joe biden comes out earlier
this year this is this is one of the
most important points when he was like
we may have we may need more lockdowns
while texas was like we're getting rid
of them and i'm like clearly joe biden
is not speaking to the world view of red
states he was speaking to new york and
california about what they want to do
based on their fears and their
perceptions so it's chicken with his
head's cut head cut off man so we're
back to chickens i like it yeah chicken
chickens and uh you saw what joe rogan
said um recently he said we're just
throwing joe roger in this episode that
it doesn't feel like we have any real
meaningful leadership like who who
believes that we have a real leader
right now even the people who voted for
him like
do you really feel like he's leading
anything i don't think so well no and
and this is this is the thing that i
think i'm i'm most concerned about so if
you if you go to a corporation or you're
in your own personal life you develop a
strategy at some point what's a strategy
it's got two parts it's got a vision and
you need resources to get there right
guess what it's always easy to have a
vision hard to find the resources so you
that you have to marry those things up
right so what's the vision of our
country where are we going to be in 30
years right nobody can articulate that
at this point in time right and without
that we're just we're rudderless we're
just drifting along in this story
i i i do hear you but i think it's
fairly obvious that what you said 30
years
so we're talking we're talking about
2051 it's gonna be barron trump uh he'll
be on his second or third term
you know uh don junior will be doing
dynasties i'm just kidding
you know i'm sure there's a lot of
people who believe that the trump
dynasty and you know whatever and uh
what's the country going to look like
are we living are we all in mansions are
we in tiny homes are we eating like
algae we're like what's going on
you can grow algae too yeah um
no i think i think it's going to be
lab-grown foods i think we're going to
have kind of like protein mush that is
flavored so
like in the matrix after you've taken
the red pill and you're in the ship you
pulled that little gruel bowl out but
that's actually a black-pilled version
of it you're going to go to the store
and you're going to say i'll have the
chili dog with uh extra cheese and i'll
get a large cola with a large fry and
it's all made of the same thing but
flavored differently
so your your hot dog comes out and the
bun is actually like a protein fungus
the hot dog itself is a is a thicker
denser protein fungus your drink is
flavored by sugars cultivated from a
protein fungus you see where i'm going
with this the french fries are just long
mushrooms or something like that
could be
but i i think that we're going to run
into trouble with that idea yeah yeah it
it it's so much more complicated how
nature actually works so there's these
micronutrients macronutrients it's not
just giving you like the base calories
which is sugar you know it's some some
little thing we need all these things
like trace amounts of selenium magnesium
and
maybe we'll we'll work all that out
right
but your your needs are going to be
different from your needs because your
gut biom's different and you have a
different genetic structure so it's just
different you're right it's it's not
you're familiar with silent yeah the the
company soylent tried making this this
food replacement
and it was interesting the idea was
can't we just figure out exactly what a
person needs and give it to them and
they don't have to worry about eating no
no because we are not uniformly produced
in a factory
every single person
is different and every day that person
is different than they were the day
before and so the problem is if you were
to say drink this bottle like it first
came in like a powder form with like a
thing of oil and you have to because you
needed fat in your diet and then they
were like okay the problem is some
people are taller and require more we're
not giving enough some people are small
and they're getting too much and they're
getting sick so now it's just like a
meal replacement shake that's in my
opinion what like slim fast
they already they make those things got
30 35 of your you know daily vitamins
and you drink it and it replaces one
meal but you still got to eat because
you don't know what you're missing
didn't that last for like a month and
then people like their their bowels were
just like ruined or whatever
didn't really work out i don't think
well it's because they they quickly
realized i'm pretty i could be wrong
about this but i'm pretty sure before
they went public like with the actual
product they said we realized you can't
actually
sustain yourself on this also the
branding i mean soylent that was the
joke it's people soylent green is people
soylent's probably not people you know
i'm really into vertical farming okay oh
i'm into vertical farming indoor
vertical farming like aero farms and
jerseys the largest one largest vertical
farms where i think the the future of
humanity might be like a vertical farm
on every block or something in a city
yeah but you know what they grow they
grow they grow lettuce greens in those
things yeah right and they don't grow
like corn and wheat and stuff they throw
them on mesh so without soil and they'll
spray the mesh with like a nutrient but
i'm wondering what's the difference of
food being grown indoors as opposed to
outdoors and natural sunlight well
there's a lot of advantages for indoors
but but for that stuff again we're
growing greens like really high value
you're getting some arugula but man does
not live on arugula alone you know so so
it's just i think they're cute i think
they have a role but to say that's how
we're going to feed people now we got to
talk megatons you know like how many how
many millions of tons of food product is
coming out of those and also
notice where the energy comes from those
are all leds are very efficient but
where's the electricity come from for
that right you just you follow this
along and you say look we already have
this nuclear reactor it's 93 million
miles away safely it's a good distance
and it provides that service for free
i'm now learning
that uh where where where i live and
what we have growing
we'd probably be able to
cover a large portion of our diets maybe
like even 60 or 70 percent just with
there's ev every day potatoes deer oh my
gosh no deer everywhere
just like they're they're they're the
people out here tell me that they're
pests they're they're a nuisance there's
so many but once you really started
living on them here's the thing i'm i'm
a hunter so the deer are everywhere
until the day of hunting season i swear
to god and they're all gone they're all
gone
it's almost like they don't want to be
shot it's the strangest thing well no
but like i today every morning i see
like three deer walking through the yard
and they're eating my apples and i'm
like stop you know jerks are reaching up
in the trees and telling them but we got
three apple trees they're just they're i
i don't know if they're wild actually it
looks like they were actually planted
we've got tons of wild pawpaw the
mulberry trees are everywhere and
everyone's mad about mulberries are
awesome because they produce fruit for
90 days like strawberries is like a week
you know but 90 days you just get
mulberry we're gonna we we took a
hammock like just and we held it
underneath and shook some branches and
we got like 300 it was insane there's
too many you walk in the yard and your
feet are turned purple and i'm like we
should actually start actually foraging
and harvesting these edible berries and
plants we got blackberries we got wine
berries we got mulberries so we actually
made jam it was amazing we made some jam
without i was having peanut butter and
jelly and then we're gonna have paw paw
we have tons of apples we made some
stuff with the apples and uh if people
didn't live in cities and spread out
then
instead of having lawns for instance
they could be growing some of their food
and it's self-sustainable and you should
grow some everybody should even if you
only grow like three percent of your
calories the difference between zero and
three percent is night and day because
you know what you learn at three percent
you're like this is hard and i'm not
that good at it or i have to learn some
stuff or oh tomatoes don't grow with any
shade at all and there's like a lot of
things you gotta learn the best part is
pretty cool i looked up the nutrition
value of mulberries if you eat 10
mulberries guess how many calories you
get six yes yes did you look it up no
six we were both wizards six calories
so if you need 2 000 calories per day
you're gonna shake that tree until
there's nothing left on it you burn more
calories shaking the tree yeah we we we
grew some zucchinis man these things
grow fast your baseball bats you don't
watch out yeah big ones yeah they get so
i saw one and it was maybe like five
inches long and then i'm like it's too
small the next day it was like like nine
and it's massive and i'm like i think
that's a little too big you know but
what do you just leave them until
they're massive or what well the best
thing is um you get pigs so my favorite
and pigs love them and they eat them
like crazy so so here's the best part
you get pigs in spring and in fall is
when you're going to be harvesting them
or sending them off to be harvested and
that's when your garden is like
overflowing with stuff you just can't
eat anymore you can't have another bean
you don't want any more zucchinis the
pigs love them and then all your apples
are dropping on the ground you just give
them to them so so in the winter this is
this is the stuff people really need to
think about
you know i can go outside and be like
look at all the fruits and all the
glorious vegetables and then winter
comes around and what did you say and
what did you preserve right so what do
people normally do you have some
chickens and you eat the chickens in the
winter to survive i mean that's not
enough chickens no it really isn't so
potatoes i mean you have to grow
something that you're going to be able
to store for a long time and you have to
think that through so this is something
this is actually near and dear to my
heart i think people should be resilient
and being food resilient is part one i
love food resilience i like being energy
resilient as well i can heat my house
four different ways now
what are they um i've got an oil furnace
i've got a wood furnace i've got um an
electrical mini split and
it's a very efficient heat pump that
that exchanges heat and cool from the
outdoor air very very efficient oh i was
watching a video about these have you
seen that that fluid that when it when
sunlight hits it it changes the
composition and then they can with an
electrical current electrical current
release the heat energy from it yeah
that's really cool um imaginable stuff
is going to be that's the hard part
storing energy is always the hard part
so this is amazing technology imagine
you have
this you have like a a you know
staggered
pipes running with this fluid the
sunlight's hitting it and then
in the winter the sunlight hits it it
changes it absorbs the energy then goes
into your basement and then converts
that back into heat and heats your home
just from the sunlight being funneled
amazing stuff thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.comcast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you